the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu good morning my name is
brian wester and i'm going to be talking
to you sorry about the speech synthesis
project our main goal for this speech
synthesis project was to simulate to
create simulated speech using a model of
the vocal tract in which we would model
the flow of air over time there is an
existing there's existing software
called new speech that already does this
and we want to deport it to sell and
then improve the speech quality that it
would afford us by using additional
computational cycles so again new speech
was originally developed for linguistics
research and but now it's available for
free under the new public license it
already models air flow in the vocal
tract in real time what this means is
that there are no pre-recorded sounds
many speech synthesizers nowadays have
very large dictionaries of sounds that
they just piece together and then try to
smooth the transition between them
however this model of attempts to
actually do what the vocal tract is
doing instead of just trying to imitate
the end result this sort of the quality
of the speech of this synthesizer the
way that it exists I is not as high as
as the current ones that use the
recorded libraries but it has potential
to be much better because you have so
much finer control over all the
different parameters so our goal was
although we have this software that
would make an acceptable speech in real
time we were hoping that we'd be able to
take advantage of the additional
computational power of cell to be able
to get get an increase in speech quality
and I will turn it over to Drew will
tell you about the new speech
so used to be specially made up of three
different major parts the first which is
just called thing a new speech engine
taken on which is probably largest
parted which is called 1a and then the
two residents model which is the final
part that actually helped puts the sound
and as yes the basic processes you take
a text input standard string and the new
speech engine will take care of that and
transform it into basica phonetic
information which will enable and deal
with and we'll take that string and
eventually convert it into these what we
call vocal tract parameters which are
basically parameters they can be sent to
the two residents model and that and
those parameters will define exactly how
this to which represents to throw in the
nasal track changes over time to
represent speech that and with those
parameters you can send signal to it and
create voice so the first part example
will take a pearl in oil string I go on
your base belong to us and transform it
into the wrinkle the phonetic movement
of it where it gives you highlighted the
actual sounds are right there
highlighted whereas various parameters
are also included in the output string
like /w determine where words are and
kind of cycle
we're sentences and various phrases and
and basically Megan your speech makes
uses a dictionary files as well as some
basic linguistic models in order to
create this kinetic output from the
Mexican Tourister so having created that
phonetic model you can then ascend into
who names but a large part of the
program which in turn will take the
phonetic information and as I said use
what a basic die phones file which has
takes a very large range of sounds and
sounds and characters and will then
transform these phonetics into direct
parameters which can represent the
changing of a throat and the National
counter nasal tract as you voice your
own speech so annoying when a has to go
through a long process of calculating
these phrases given the whole the rhythm
the intonation of the phrase it's being
given to monet and also a very important
part of the de- processes by taking each
phrase and the posture is what we call
them the output taking looking at the
phrase and piece by piece examining the
sounds and realizing that as as postures
of the throat change there are important
things changes being made between
they're basically having some sort of
basically a slow change between a
gradual conversion as opposed to sudden
change in the actual shape so then
having outputted the basic posture is
you finally send it to the tube
residents ball or CRM which will then
take the vocal tract which is divided
into eight sections in this model and
send a basically a sort of signal off of
a sine wave through the modified to
present model and therefore all the
changes that occur as time goes on and
the postures which change the basically
the widths of the tube at various stages
will then cause different speech
patterns to come out and basically
create an actual speech pattern which is
usually recognized
so basically use these three parts from
a basic string to phonetics to throat
postures until finally you get the
actual speech up so now which is the two
presidents model so we already talked
about how Mooney outputs like two
parameters based on you know transitions
between different words and postures and
so on and the two presidents model
actually simulates the physics of the
vocal tract first you have a glottal
source if you have done any you know
linguistics you might have heard the
little clicking sound iguala source
makes there are different ways to
simulate the glottal source now the
ideally the way you have a good natural
glottal source is you have a simulation
of the physics between two oscillating
masses as you know air passes through
them now back in the days when say you
know people were doing speech research
on canoe speech it's actually simulating
the physics of a goddess was not
possible so what they did instead was
you know they would try a half sine wave
or they would research the most natural
sounding glottal pulse shape initialize
a wave table and do table lookup on it
updating it as you know with amplitude
and so on to change it a little by
little so one of our goals was possibly
to because we harness the additional
computational power and make more
natural sounding street and now i'll
talk about allocating to resources
there's a for example new speech Monet
there is not as much computation Monet
has a lot of rules for example between
postures and postures like different
shapes of vocal tracks you can't just do
in linear interpolation to smoothly
change there are different rules because
in order to change between the postures
which greatly affects the speech this
was much harder to improve on like to
paralyze
in the tube residence model and a lot
more computation in fact the thing that
took probably most computation was after
we got our signal data from the mouth
and of the simulation we would have to
up sample or down sample it and that was
something that had a lot of potential to
be parallelized however when you were
simulating to residents model you could
only update the signal inside the vocal
tract incrementally if you were to break
it up there was a possibility that there
would be like a lot of pops in between
if when you try to space them together
we thought about trying to resolve that
with interpolation between forms there
were these there were nested loops the
main synthesized thing had to Lester
loops you have a posture and then you
simulate on the posture in between the
postures and that took the most
computation as well as updating the
glottal wave table all right now hand it
off to Omari to explain challenges ok so
the Tiran algorithm which is we most
focus on trying to so we most tried to
focus on parallelizing the trm algorithm
because both the new speech and Monet
were almost entirely just dictionary
lookups involving large amounts of
memory with not that much computation so
we didn't really tried that there was
really that much potential for
paralyzing those so we did a look at the
tasks that were being done on trm
profiled them and you can see the what
took most of the time was the noise
generator part like the attempt of the
global source that was infant that was
in I mean that was being put into the
tubes and the actual updates of where
the tubes are supposed to be as they
were shifting and so unfortunately on
the main loop as this was updating it
was a very very fast about 15 micro
seconds so it was it would be pretty
difficult to you know
to it for example several SPU's for as
fast as we needed them to like
considering how how communication costs
affect that so the parallelism was not
very simple to use our main original
idea for exploding parallel ilysm was to
make a pipeline of the various parts of
the trm model maybe like using three or
four SPU's like one for each part of the
throat as the sound would go from one to
the next so that all of them would be
engaged simultaneously like going from
one posture to the next and I like
linear fashion but unfortunately the the
loop the timing for this was very very
fast in the order of about 70 kilohertz
which is like many times a second for
SPU's to be transferring data back and
forth to each other with mailboxes in
memory so that was somewhat difficult
unfortunately with this problem with
this project we own face a number of
challenges the first and foremost being
that new speech is written in a
programming language most of us weren't
familiar with and it's huge like Monet
for example is 30,000 lines it's hardly
documented and yeah and it took a fair
amount of time just like reading through
and figuring out what was going on
additionally because it uses new step
which is sort of a GOI library the calls
are asynchronous and it makes it
tremendously difficult to debug as well
um I had tried to convert part of it to
C++ to try to get the tube running on
one of the sps and that took three days
in and of itself and I ended up having
to toss that attempt out um another
problem we had was dynamic core
alignment in objective-c most of the
objects are stored as dynamic pointers
and basically in objective-c there's
also no life Malik a line or anything of
that nature so we couldn't really
transfer any of the objects from the
objective-c memory area I guess to the
SPU's to work on the data and then send
them back um so what is working now we
are able to do line buffered text in in
the new speech engine um and translate
that to utterances so the phonetic
pronunciations and get to the point
where we would execute the tube model
unfortunately one of the like is our bug
in new speech potentially is preventing
us from properly execute
the tube model right now so so that's
one thing we're having problems with
additionally on the tube runs on the PPE
we've been trying to get the tube to run
on the sve but it's not going well
partly because of the the dynamic
pointer alignment issue and partly
because of some other things we've run
into um currently not working as um drew
had mentioned there is there are a lot
of dictionary lookups in the sort of the
pre-processing pre-processing stage of
the of the pipeline I guess and there's
a bug and new step where it won't
recognize it won't parse the dictionary
if it's above a certain size the
dictionary has I believe seventy
thousand entries it takes up almost
three megs but if there are I believe
more than like more than 3000 entries in
the dictionary it just doesn't parse we
have no idea why a scoot past so to
conclude this was a tremendously
difficult problem like there are a bunch
of data dependencies and the
synchronization is very very close
however we feel that with us with more
time and with more experience with the
codebase we would have been able to
parallelize it and the parallelization
can almost definitely help the vocal
quality in terms of naturalness getting
for example as Joyce mentioned a higher
quality grotto source on speaker
identification valid identification for
example the when when you pronounce
different vowels sometimes the quality
of the glottal source changes and lastly
it would be worth the time to rewrite
the whole thing from scratch skipping
neustadt skipping objective-c and going
with
c++ or most likely see for the whole
thing um thank you any questions you
guys took a fine-grained approach which
you're splitting the application across
different looked at splitting the second
occasion across different units you seem
sincere I mean you're synthesizing
completely independent words let's say
right could could you just run the whole
application on an FPU I mean I their
engineering they're bringing from a
paralyzation standpoint can you just
take the whole application and run it
for example on different words so the
aam so I believe you me you're
suggesting we run the tube on different
SVG's and then like feed data to the
separate instances of the tube from the
pp well including well I guess the whole
process is from one like so then so does
the big stumbling block for us was that
there isn't currently an objective c
compiler compiler for the ESPYs so we
can't run the SP code run the
objective-c code on the ESPYs at all
30-9 fresh would that be a better
Carla's agent trying to find anyone um
possibly so one of the guys
disadvantages of sort of splitting up
words is that there is state that
connects the different lights continuous
state that connects in different
postures of the vocal tract all the way
through the utterance and so we would
have to have to possibly some prediction
possibly some interpolation to figure
out how to connect the different
separate utterances which should have
been produced really one sentence at a
time yeah that might be an option yes